[Musique]
ce sont de petites gravure à la fois
modeste et grandiose qui témoigne de
l'immensité de territoire et du mode de
vie de ses habitants
qu'est-ce qu'il ya ici aujourd'hui ça
m'émeut dans d'en parler je ne
m'attendais jamais à ce que ça se rende
ici
[Musique]
entre 2014 et 2019 l'artiste ligne
bastien est allé à la rencontre d'inuits
pour la plupart des sculpteurs de pierre
et leur a transmis sa passion pour la
gravure
c'était très au courant des scud de la
présence des blancs dans les communautés
depuis quelques siècles
j'étais très au courant des effets de la
colonisation
je ne voulais pas arriver dans une
communauté et tout prendre et ne rien
laisser
elle a mis sur pied des ateliers
itinérants et entrepris de former des
artistes formateurs dans une dizaine de
villages
gouverner tout elle a rencontré la
sculptrice de glace maggie n'a partout
car
le travail de maguy c'est un travail
d'une grande finesse c'est très très
beau c'est ça représente bien le nunavik
c'est une fille qui s'intéresse beaucoup
à la tradition
donc elle avait beaucoup de choses à
communiquer demain
aux
états unis était un
atout
[Musique]
avec du formans les soixante estampes
retenu pour l'exposition présente des
scènes de la vie quotidienne du grand
nord mais aussi des personnages de
légende réalisé par des hommes et des
femmes jeunes et moins jeunes ici le
titre de l'oeuvre ces femmes se
transforme en loup alors dans les
histoires inuits que souvent des
personnages qui se transforme en animal
on voit des éléments traditionnels dont
l'igloo le harpon mais c'est dans un
iphone c'est très actuel et puis pour
moi sacré en parle au pont avec les
traditions et des précipitations qui
sont plus actuel
la sélection des oeuvres à poser des
défis particuliers lille bastiais s'est
entouré de deux femmes artistes inuits
dans ma guina partout pour faire ses
choix pour les femmes c'était l'histoire
les histoires est importante ce n'est
pas juste de faire une belle image
c'était de communiquer quelque chose qui
était important au sujet de la culture
en train de rapper dingue fort est
attendu au niveau sans le code
à distance
la gravure à mener ma guina partout vers
le dessin il travaille actuellement à la
production d'un livre à colorier qui
illustre aussi sa culture et son
l'environnement tout comme l'ensemble
des oeuvres exposées
unique
et 28 ans merci sam chamanisme s ouvrir
je suis aussi très fier de montrer au
public ce qui sort du nunavik qui est
autre qu est-ce qu on peut publier dans
les journaux elle est aidée sur les
drames qui ont nunavik et oui il y en a
des drames mais il ya aussi des choses
magnifiques qui se passe là-bas et
toutes les images qui sont six en
témoigne
l'exposition résurgence lestang pour
nunavik 2014 2019 est présentée au musée
d'art de joliette jusqu'au 9 janvier
prochain
[Musique]